[Music]
the following sentences have never ever
been uttered before in human history
[Music]
I've lost so much weight ever since I
started bowling I can't stop undressing
this Hyundai salesman with my eyes that
was a pretty good fish concert but it
was way too short nothing makes me feel
like a winner like eating alone at Baja
Fresh
harder Mitch McConnel
I'm DVR in it so nobody talked about
bones
sir Anthony Hopkins had a scheduling
conflict so we've decided to offer the
role to Busta Rhymes hey
another creationist one jeopardy
I hope my neighbor tells me about his
rowing machine again I'm gonna ask my
plastic surgeon to give me the Conan and
the Oscar for Best Screenplay goes to
Planet of the dildoes
uncle Barry's been in the bathroom for
over an hour I'd like to go in there
next
[Music]
when I need tips on interacting with
women there's no one I trust more than
this reddit subgroup I think the best
thing to do is just trust the Russians
I'm having a hard time enjoying this
oral sex
[Music]
[Applause]
you